يزور المبعوث الامريكيه الخاص للشرق
الاوسط افرت ماجورت بغداد بالتزامني مع
زياره قائد فايلق القدس الايراني الجنرال
الاسماعيلي القائد مسؤول بارز في الاطار
التنسيقيه اكد لموقع المدى ان زيارتين خطط
لهما في وقت سابق بهدف في فتح حوار مباشر
بين دولتيهما بشكل غير عالمي
الزيرتان ستمهدان حسب المسؤول لوضع خطوط
عريضه لبدء جولات حوار جديده حول الملف
النووي في مقابل تخفيف الضغط على العراق
بقضيه التداول الدولار واستفاء ايران
ايرادات الغاز المصدر للعراق بالدولار
بدلا من الدماء
وعن تخطيط زياراتين يشير المسؤول العراقي
الى انه جرت ترتيب همم لذلك في حوار بغداد
الشهر الماضي برعايه فرنسيه وفرنسا هي
الساعه الى ان يساعد العراق في دفع طهران
للحوار بشان الاوضاع في سوريا والازمه
الاوكرانيه باعتبارها حليفا قويا لروسيا
وهي حليف سياسي مطلع اشترت هو الاخر عدم
الكشف عن اسمه اشار الى ان المبعوثه
الامريكي تحدث عن مخاوف من تجدد قصف
الفصائل للسفاره الامريكيه والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه الاخرى